we've been talking more and more about
Mike Pence the vice president our
fearless co-leader within the context of
the Trump Russia investigation what did
Mike Pence know about what was going on
with regards to Russia contacts when did
he know it if Donald Trump were to leave
the Oval Office for whatever reason
would Mike Pence be a credible and sort
of clean in the untainted sense
replacement for Donald Trump or might
Mike Pence himself be taken down as well
and months ago we speculated that Mike
Pence might have accepted the VP
position might have accepted being
Donald Trump's running mate on the off
chance that Trump would be removed as a
way to become president himself we now
have an absolutely riveting new report
from the Atlantic by McKay Coppins which
reveals that when those infamous access
hollywood grabbed him by the
you-know-what tapes came out of donald
trump saying hey this is what i do too
famous to women because i'm famous don't
even wait don't even wait I just I just
do it Mike Pence we now know got in
touch with the Republican National
Committee and made it abundantly clear
that hey he'd be willing to replace
Donald Trump as the Republican nominee
on the ticket and in fact while all the
Access Hollywood tape stuff was
happening
Trump was calling pence we've now
learned and Mike Pence was not even
returning the guy's phone calls and it's
been reported that during this phase of
sort of disconnect between Pence and
Trump Trump sent a Trump received a
letter from Mike Pence saying that pence
needed to think about whether he could
even stay on the ticket with Donald
Trump which are a combination just a
group of stunning revelations and this
report in the Atlantic also exposes that
this went even further Republican
officials after the release of the
Access Hollywood grab him by the you
know what tapes Republican officials
were thinking how could we push Donald
Trump off the ticket and they went as
far as to think about maybe making it a
pence Condoleezza Rice ticket and I have
to tell you this actually improves my
opinion of the Republican Party slightly
and I don't mean a lot I really
mean in the slightest sense and what I'm
talking about is the Republican Party
was at least thinking about the idea of
pushing Donald Trump out after the
Access Hollywood tape that tells us that
is if nothing else they at least
realized the political liability of that
recording now it says nothing about
their morality it says nothing about
their ethics and ultimately it was for
nothing since Donald Trump did stay on
the ticket and Republicans voted for him
but if I considered the GOP call it 100
percent out of it learning that at least
there was a discussion of pushing Trump
out makes my opinion that there only 99
percent out of it I think that was just
their out though right the Access
Hollywood tape would give them a reason
to oust Trump and then pence would have
stood a much better chance of winning
than Trump did at the time at times
certainly a way Pence's negative
favorability numbers to Hillary
Clinton's they're a lot better right so
do you think though because what you're
pointing out is interesting do you think
that the Access Hollywood tape didn't
actually change the Republican insiders
opinion of Trump that they always were
sort of wondering how could we push him
out and it might have missed if you have
vented it presented an opportunity
that's interesting what's clear is that
pence never realistically believed in
Trump as far as his politics are
concerned right he saw it as a way being
Trump's running mate for Mike Pence was
a way to get close to the Oval Office
and in the end maybe it could get him
into the oval office because Mike Pence
is the schemer right Pence is a genuine
right-wing ideologue for lack of a
better term which is part of why I don't
think we're better off with a
hypothetical Mike Pence in the White
House than with Donald Trump but don't
think for even a moment that this
excuses Mike Pence's behavior he's
enabling the total degeneracy of the
President of the United States by
pretending that the guy is normal if
that's I guess what Pence is doing by
defending Donald Trump in public and the
other thing to remember to get back to
the many scenarios that we can imagine
where pence becomes president because
Trump goes we're sort of acting like if
Trump goes Pence will just naturally
become president unopposed when we think
about Donald Trump as the vindictive me
first or only me type of guy
is it really logical to assume that
Trump would just allow pence to become
president of the United States I
actually wonder if Trump has to go
whether he would try to take pence down
with him yeah and even before we get to
all of that will Trump try to oust pence
now Oh Trump can't fire him because
pence is elected right he was on the
ticket as vice president yeah but he
could try to pressure pence to leave and
given the chance that pence has that
becoming president now I don't think he
would go along with that
I can't imagine Donald Trump calmly and
respectfully leaving the presidency to
pence I guess that that's where I am and
whether the scenario is is what Pat is
describing or some other scenario it's
very difficult to imagine Trump saying
Mike Pence is gonna do a great job and
I'm leaving the country in good hands I
don't see it send me your thoughts if
you disagree with me or if you agree I'm
on Twitter at D Pakman we will take a
break and be back after this today's
program is sponsored by live lingua the
immersive one-on-one language learning
system it's no secret to many of you
that English is not my first language
Spanish is my first language I was born
in Argentina and moved to the US and
learned English
I've also dabbled in learning French and
with significantly less success Hebrew
over the years and what I can tell you
from my experience is that the method of
full immersion and learning from native
speakers really is the way to go and
this really dovetails with exactly what
live lingua offers to you and they are
actually offering two things number one
I've told you before about the first
lesson free with live lingua in addition
to that live lingua is offering 20% off
gift cards which make not only great
gifts for family and friends it's better
than one of those weird knives you were
thinking of getting but they'll never
use anyway and will probably end up in
the trash and you'll end up humiliated
or embarrassed don't do it get a gift of
meaning give the gift of language you
can go to live lingua kaam slash Pakman
get 20% off gift cards you can use the
gift card on yourself if you want and
still new live linguist subscribers get
their first lesson free check it out
live lingua comm slash Pakman